merci Philippe mouillé de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure cette sénateur les
républicains des Deux-Sèvres
vice-présidents de la commission des
affaires sociales on va parler du projet
de loi pleine emploi dans quelques
instants et de la question des
soulèvements de la terre puisque
Sainte-Soline se trouve dans votre
département mais d'abord l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est aussi ce rapport du
corps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui sera remis officiellement
et malgré la réforme des retraites le
régime ne sera pas équilibré en 2030
contrairement à scrap promis le
gouvernement c'est ce que dit le rapport
est-ce que le gouvernement a trop cédé
aux républicain pendant cette réforme
alors je sais pas si la trocéder mais
d'abord une remarque sur le rapport du
corps qu'on va connaître d'ailleurs dans
les jours qui viennent on a entendu le
corps avant la réforme des retraites il
fallait finalement c'était à peine
nécessaire et quelque part ensuite
quelques mois après c'est très forme on
considère que c'est pas suffisant donc
déjà je pense que sur l'analyse il y a
un vrai débat je parle pas des chiffres
on nous les verrons après de façon
générale qu'est-ce qu'on constate c'est
que la situation déjà est compliquée on
va bien que malgré la réforme on a à
peine en 2030 le nouveau le niveau de
l'équilibre mais ça veut dire quelque
part il fallait faire cette réforme
imaginez la situation et ce sera
intéressant de regarder l'analyse du
corps la situation si la réforme n'était
pas faite voilà donc moi je crois plutôt
ça renforce globalement la nécessité de
la réforme même si ça pose la question
de la capacité pour le gouvernement
d'avoir des données précises chiffrées
pour anticiper les évolutions donc ça
pose la question du corps se pose des
questions
mais est-ce que donc pour revenir à ma
question parce que il y a eu des
concessions qui ont été faites à votre
groupe pour que le texte soit voté ici
au Sénat est-ce qu'il y en a eu trois
est-ce qu'elles ont trop coûté est-ce
que du coup elles empêchent d'atteindre
l'équilibre en 2030 alors je crois que
d'abord sur l'équilibre on va voir les
chiffres on se rapproche de
l'équilibrillé une évolution qui est
plutôt favorable après il fallait
négocier il fallait que cette retraite
soit la moins douloureuse possible pour
un certain nombre de Français donc je
crois que ça fait partie des discussions
la négociation mais de nouveau c'est le
débat de la méthode c'est-à-dire que si
on avait une méthode qui anticipé une
réforme fondamentale comme celle-ci je
pense que on aurait pu traiter les
choses différemment et peut-être avoir
une réforme plus rigoureuse par rapport
à l'objectif d'atteindre de l'équilibre
tout en faisant en sorte que les
Français puissent se retrouver dans
cette évolution voilà donc voilà un
premier effort mais on va regarder très
très près ce rapport puisque pour
l'instant il n'est pas donné
officiellement on a des brides qui
arrivent notamment par les médias mais
en tout cas c'est un appel très
sérieusement et je pense que la
Commission d'aller faire ce sel doit se
saisir notamment de ce sujet là et ça
pose la question d'une nouvelle réforme
et d'un nouveau report de l'âge à 65 ans
peut-être d'abord l'adaptation de
l'existant et de en tirer les premiers
bilans
autre sujet qui alerte les sénateurs il
y a eu pas moins de quatre questions
d'actualité il y a au gouvernement sur
la question des dépenses publiques et de
ces 10 milliards d'économies annoncés
par le gouvernement en début de semaine
est-ce que vous défendez ces 10
milliards d'économies vous ont défendez
la nécessité il faut les faire pour vous
alors oui alors je sais pas si c'est 10
milliards en tous les cas il y a un
effort qui est nécessaire par rapport au
fait de redresser le niveau dépenses
publiques on voit bien on est dans le
rouge aujourd'hui on sort du quoiqu'il
en coûte alors j'avoue que à la fois
l'objectif c'est un objet que nous
portons ici au Sénat dans la majorité
mais la façon dont le ministre de
l'Économie l'a annoncé interpelle lui
qui a passé son temps à faire des
chèques et qui d'un seul coup réagit et
qui pointent en plus directement les
dépenses de santé voilà donc j'imagine
de la perception pour les professionnels
de santé ils sont forcément des
réactions donc de nouveau c'est le
travail du Parlement de proposer au
gouvernement des pistes nous en avons la
commission des finances enales la
Commission de la phase sociale agaçante
de proposition en matière et d'économie
et de recherche notamment autour de la
fraude social donc il faut qu'on puisse
les mêmes que celles de Bruno Le Maire
Bruno Le Maire parmi les pistes alors il
y a la question du logement il y a la
question des aides au carburant mais
aussi la question des dépenses de santé
ça c'est un sujet que vous suivez de
près explosion des arrêts maladie
dérivent des dépenses en médicaments il
veut faire des économies là-dessus vous
le suivez alors sur le sur les maladies
la réponse est oui seul médicament je
suis beaucoup plus prudent parce que à
la fois le niveau de prescription des
médicaments mais à travers le
financement médicament il y a aussi tout
le financement de la recherche donc
voilà donc on peut pas faire un résumé
aussi rapide on connaît aujourd'hui on
n'a pas tenu le maire on connaît les
aujourd'hui les Suisses sur lesquels
nous devons regarder très près mais je
vais vers le sud de la santé doit être
pris avec parcimonie parce qu'on voit
bien aujourd'hui que la santé va mal en
France et on peut jeter comme ça une
information disant c'est sur ce point-là
qu'on doit faire des économies le débat
doit être global et je crois que c'est
le travail du Parlement au-delà des
annonces du ministre il y a une question
aussi qui interpelle c'est qu'elle parle
et collectivités doivent-elles prendre à
l'effort les élus locaux les
associations d'élus ont boycotter ses
assises des finances publiques elles ont
une raison oui parce que on voit bien le
grand des zones logiques ou l'état
reprend la main sur quelque part les
capacités financières des collectivités
on voit bien on a un gros doute
maintenant la sur l'autonomie des
collectivités et en même temps l'État
prend la main et nous dit vous de faire
des efforts on a envie de dire écoutez
gérer d'abord l'état comme les
collectivités on pourra discuter voilà
donc de nouveau il faut un dialogue et
ça peut pas uniquement ascendant
descendant et voilà donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les collectifs leurs
preuves de leur efficacité à l'état de
peut-être regarder comment fonctionne
on va parler de la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre et pour ça on
va aller du côté de chez vous retrouver
Emmanuel Vautier bonjour Emmanuel
journaliste a pressé en merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous avec vous on va revenir
sur cette question de la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre prononcé hier
par des crée en conseil des ministres et
ce mouvement on en a entendu parler à
l'occasion de la manifestation de sainte
Soline chez vous Philippe mouiller mais
il est né à Notre-Dame-des-Landes
Emmanuel oui c'est un mouvement qu'on
connaît bien ici en Loire-Atlantique
d'ailleurs c'est pas anodin hier soir il
y avait des rassemblements un peu
partout en France et particulièrement à
Nantes où on avait un millier de
personnes réunies monsieur le sénateur
qu'elle regarde vous vous portez sur ce
cette dissolution des soulèvements de la
Terre et sur les interpellations qui ont
lieu comment est-ce que vous vous
qualifiez ce mouvement alors d'abord
juste un point important moi j'étais
présent dans cette souligne au moment de
la manifestation j'ai observé ce qui
s'est passé et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un message important de marquer le
coût de faire le fait de considérer
qu'une structure qui est des pratiques
qui sans cesse je dirais dans dans
l'insécurité qui aujourd'hui renie
l'État de droit et bien soit sanctionné
par ce pas par cette action après on
s'en est d'accord ça va pas modifier les
idées ça a pas modifier les mouvements
mais je crois que ça vous pour les
victimes les victimes que j'ai pu
rencontrer c'est un message qui est
important on est il y a un état de droit
et je crois que même si on a des
revendications même s'il y a des causes
qui peuvent être portées par un certain
nombre d'associations je crois que
c'était pour moi c'était une décision
qui est importante
oui en même temps est-ce que cette
mesure prise est-ce qu'elle risque pas
d'être à l'inverse de l'objectif
recherche et on l'a vu nous sur Nantes
avec un mouvement qui s'appelait une
entrée voltée il y avait eu pareil des
annonces politiques en disant
dissolution de notre révolté et puis au
final un an après il y avait pas le
début d'une procédure disait l'avocat de
l'entrée volté le mouvement a changé de
nom et le mouvement il existe toujours
aujourd'hui donc concrètement est-ce que
on voit bien là sur les soulèvements de
la terre leurs avocats disent que bah il
y a pas de base juridique réellement
pour pouvoir prononcer cette dissolution
alors j'imagine que le gouvernement avec
le ministre de l'Intérieur a regardé à
traiter le sujet moi je crois que
au-delà de l'efficacité c'est-à-dire que
le fait d'arrêter un mouvement on
n'arrête pas de mouvement avec une
dissolution d'une association je crois
que c'est une reconnaissance par rapport
aux victimes sur le comportement d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs voilà et je
crois que aujourd'hui il y a des
messages on doit donner des messages aux
Français en disant c'est pas parce que à
un moment donné une minorité de
personnes violente réagissent à des
situations que il doit avoir raison et
que la France doit s'arrêter au regard
uniquement de ces mouvements voilà je
crois que pour se mettre autour de la
table à un moment donné et bien il faut
avoir une capacité dialoguer avec des
gens qui ne respectabilité quand vous
êtes dans l'action violente quand vous
êtes dans le déni démocratie à un moment
donné je crois qu'il doit avoir une
réaction
Emmanuel une autre question là-dessus
oui en même temps on voit bien la
question que c'est interroge sur le fond
c'est comment renouer du dialogue on
voit que de sur des manifestations des
rassemblements on est sur des mouvements
de plus en plus radicaux tant du côté
des manifestants que de la réponse des
forces de l'Orbe on le constate nous ici
sur Nantes il y a très régulièrement des
manifestations qui finissent avec des
heures Rennes et aussi concernée vous
l'avez vécu sur Sainte Soline comment
réussir à un moment à retisser du lien
retisser du dialogue je crois qu'il faut
surtout avoir des interlocuteurs qui est
la volonté de dialoguer parce qu'on
parle des manifestations mais moi qui
vit au quotidien sur un territoire tendu
il y a pas que les manifestations chaque
rendez-vous chaque rencontre on a acquis
pour sa voiture enfin on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas des points de
guérilla permanente qui te met en place
donc c'est plus fort que simplement une
manifestation violente on est en train
d'installer un climat d'insécurité
permanent vis-à-vis de décideurs qui
pointent des orientations donc c'est un
vrai débat autour de la démocratie
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui moi j'ai des
élus locaux qui décident de ne plus
aller aux réunions de la commission
d'école de l'eau parce qu'ils ont peur
d'être agressés on en est là vous voyez
ça dépasse donc si on fait rien si on
considère que on doit pas réagir parce
que à un moment donné c'est l'expression
de d'un point de vue dans ce cas là je
sais pas où on va mais je suis très
inquiet donc je pense qu'il y a une
réponse à la fois il y a un débat
d'ouverture du dialogue avec des
interlocuteurs qu'on réellement la
capacité de dialoguer et en même temps
il y a des bas de fermeté quel que soit
le côté mais on doit réagir parce que
sinon on s'en va tout droit dans une
situation qui est extrêmement
inquiétante si vous parlez d'agression
d'élus Philippe mouiller Emmanuel on va
dire un mot de votre une consacrée à la
ferme aux relais l'ancien maire de
Saint-Brévin
c'est ça on a appris hier de garde à vue
de personnes placées en garde à vue
alors on n'a pas encore beaucoup
d'éléments sur le profil des deux
personnes on sait que sont des personnes
qui ont une quarantaine et une
soixantaine d'années alors les sources
discord c'est un peu discord il y a des
personnes qui disent qu'ils seraient
proches de l'ultra droite proche de de
des opposants au projet de cadas à
Saint-Brévin néanmoins eux les le
collectif anti-cadan nous dit que il y a
pas de membre chez eux néanmoins il y a
bien des personnes du collectif
anti-canada qui ont été entendus en tout
cas on voit que l'enquête avance sur ce
dossier important
quand on voit je parle sur le contrôle
d'Emmanuel que la nouvelle maire de
Saint-Brevin récemment lieu a déjà
déposé des plantes est-ce qu'il faut
être inquiet de ce climat qui perdure
tout à fait on est dans le même registre
la sélectorat et voilà globalement tous
ces mouvements extrémistes sont tout à
combattre et ça renvoie le débat de la
place des élus de la parole des élus et
la protection des élus voilà mais c'est
un mouvement de fond là on a on met
l'éclairage sur une situation qui est
exceptionnelle mais c'est un mouvement
de fond moi qui suis à la rencontre des
mères en permanence on voit aujourd'hui
tous les miens nous racontent que pour
une décision pour un problème
d'urbanisme et bien maintenant les actes
sont violents par la parole par la par
la force et donc je crois que de nouveau
il y a besoin d'une vraie réaction de
réinstaller finalement gérer la
notoriété de l'élu local et puis sa
capacité à porter une parole qui sont
reconnues et notamment à travers les
actions de justice quoi merci beaucoup
Emmanuel Vautier merci d'avoir été avec
nous et on remonte la Une infirmores de
garde à vue c'est à la Une de Presse
Océan ce matin merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin on regarde on va parler de
ce qui se passe au Sénat de l'audition
comme vous avez fait hier d'Olivier du
socle le ministre ou l'auditionner sur
sa loi plein emploi qui arrive en séance
le 10 juillet on va voir les temps forts
de cette audition à la Audrey vitale
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour et Audrey
le ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
est donc venu détailler le projet de loi
pleine emploi hier devant les sénateurs
de la commission des affaires sociales
Pôle emploi qui va devenir
france-travail au plus tard le 1er
janvier 2025 syntaxe est voté oui un
nouveau nom c'est marketing ça traduit
la volonté du gouvernement de
transformer totalement le service public
de l'emploi et de l'insertion il faut
changer les choses parce qu'actuellement
on a un taux chômage de 7,1% alors même
que deux tiers des PME disent avoir du
mal à recruter si on veut atteindre le
plein emploi c'est-à-dire passer en
dessous des 5% c'est une promesse de
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron il va falloir
faire mieux ou en tout cas différemment
alors comment on fait d'abord on
centralise les offres et les demandes
ensuite on essaye d'identifier les
personnes qui sont éloignées de l'emploi
le texte prévoit donc une inscription
automatique à France travail le futur
nom de Pôle emploi de tous les
bénéficiaires du RSA et de toutes les
personnes inscrites à la Mission locale
actuellement 40 % ne le sont pas sauf
que inscrire plus de monde quand on veut
réduire le chômage ça a laissé les
sénateurs interrogatifs je vous propose
d'écouter justement les interrogations
de René Paul Savary et puis la réponse
du ministre en deux temps
monsieur le ministre ça sert à rien
d'inscrire des gens qui sont au RSA et
qui sont des gens qui doivent bénéficier
d'une insertion sociale faut surtout pas
pour certains les mettre au travail chez
des élèves on connaît tout ça il y a des
gens qui ne faut pas mettre au travail
il y a d'autres actions à faire sur la
faut pas les inscrire au travail ne
dites pas que c'est une loi de plein
emploi va c'est pas 5 % que vous allez
avoir en inscrivant tout ça au chômage
Vous avez passé 10%, le taux de chômage
est calculé sur la base les critères du
Bureau international du Travail et non
pas sur le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
inscrits en fin de mois chez Pôle Emploi
donc l'augmentation des difm de Pôle
emploi ne se traduit pas mécaniquement
par une augmentation du taux de chômage
la loi prévoit que pour les allocataires
du RSA les plus éloignés de l'emploi il
n'y ait pas d'orientation des
professionnels mais simplement une
orientation sociale avec un point de
situation tous les 6 à 12 mois de
manière accompagner dans une première
phase qui ne serait que sociale avant
d'aller vers l'emploi monsieur mouiller
sur ces inscriptions automatiques vous
avez demandé hier à ce que toutes les
personnes qui demanderaient être
reconnues travailleur handicapé soit
inscrite automatiquement à France
travail pourquoi pour pouvoir bénéficier
justement des mesures d'accompagnement
et surtout sur un public qui parfois a
envie de travailler mais pense que on
continue le handicap ils n'auront jamais
de possibilités donc ils abandonnent
même l'idée de rechercher un emploi donc
pour moi ce qui est important c'est pas
forcément le débat du tout de chômage
c'est permettre à des personnes qui ont
une vraie volonté de s'insérer d'avoir
des outils une ouverture sur les outils
à la fois d'insertion mais également de
recherche d'emploi est-ce qu'il y a des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
osent pas faire complètement je connais
beaucoup je vois que c'est vraiment dans
le milieu on a beaucoup de personnes
lourdement handicapées qui ont des
capacités intellectuelles qui ont des
capacités importantes qui peuvent sans
problème gérer être inséré dans une
entreprise et considérant la nature de
leur handicap il y a finalement
abandonne l'idée même de rechercher un
emploi voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
pouvoir leur proposer de façon
automatique voilà après ça fonctionne ou
pas mais en tous les cas il faut essayer
de les accompagner dans un contrat
d'engagement
la création de France travail qui doit
remplacer Pôle Emploi si le texte est
adopté ça vise à mieux coordonner les
acteurs du service public de l'emploi
parce que à l'heure actuelle il y a une
partie qui Géral une partie par la
région une partie par les départements
le gouvernement veut que les demandeurs
d'emploi n'est qu'une seule porte
d'entrée c'est nécessaire pour vous
alors la porte d'entrée la réponse est
oui la coordination la réponse c'est oui
mais la centralisation la réponse est
non parce qu'à un moment donné l'idée
c'est quoi c'est que il faut adapter
finalement au territoire aux situations
au type de public les outils et donc les
portes d'entrée doivent être uniques
mais à partir finalement d'outils
adaptés par rapport au public et donc le
fait de mettre tout le monde sous la
gérer sous la coupe du préfet la partie
par contre m'inquiète parce que la
centralisation n'est pas une bonne chose
on est plutôt sur des politiques
territoriales voilà donc il faut avoir
cette nuance là ça va d'ailleurs un
travail que nous allons faire la
commission sociale pour apporter un peu
de nuance vous allez modifier ce point
bien sûr
conçu par le gouvernement on travaille
dessus pour éviter ces trop de force
centralisation et bien entendu en tirer
le meilleur la coordination et on voit
bien c'est au Sénat on travaille depuis
de nombreuses années sur le débat de la
régionalisation des politiques d'emploi
régionalisation pourquoi parce que ce
qui se passe son nouvel équitaine chez
moi les besoins en matière d'emploi le
type de demandeur n'est pas le même que
dans la région Rhône-Alpes ailleurs donc
il faut qu'on ait ce travail là si vous
recentralisez en disant une politique
nationale et tout le monde marche pas ça
ne fonctionne pas donc il faut savoir
coordonner donc il y a des bons gérer
des bons sujets dans le texte de loi
mais il faut avoir une nuance il faut
avoir des respecter les acteurs locaux
et surtout ceux qui ont des résultats
aujourd'hui
voici de conditionner le RSA oui le
bénéficiaire du RSA devra souscrire à un
contrat d'engagement d'une durée de 15 à
20h hebdomadaire ce contrat se consiste
en des immersions des ateliers de
formation c'est pas forcément du travail
ou du bénévolat s'il est signé mais
qu'il n'est pas respecté les droits
pourront être suspendus c'est une étape
qui a été rajoutée pour éviter de passer
tout de suite à la radiation la mesure
est actuellement en cours
d'expérimentation dans 18 départements
et c'est un problème pour certains
sénateurs qui l'ont fait savoir hier
pourquoi légiférer quand on n'a pas
encore de retour d'expérience écoutez la
réponse du ministration
la loi prévoit la généralisation de ce
nouvel accompagnement à partir de 2025
et donc les expérimentations qui sont
menées permettent et ça n'est pas du
niveau législatif mais permettent de
voir tout ce qui peut marcher tout ce
qui peut être recommandé pour la
génération de la généralisation 2025 et
la loi nous permet par contre de fixer
un cadre dont nous avons besoin et sans
être prescriptif et d'ailleurs c'était
aussi une demande ou des départements de
France de ne pas enfermer leur action en
termes d'insertion et d'accompagnement
dans une liste d'activités posées par la
loi monsieur mouillé ça vous étonne
aussi cette manière de procéder en
légifère avant le retour d'expérience
je crois que clairement nous sommes
plutôt nous favorables à cette démarche
là même si sur la mise en oeuvre on va
quand même s'appuyer sur le peu
d'expérience même l'expérimentation
n'est pas terminée parce que René Paul
Salvary il a très bien dit dans tout
cela dans ce public là avant tout
d'abord une démarche sociale souvent et
donc il faut pas on peut pas mettre tout
le monde tout de suite dans une démarche
de recherche d'emploi
donc voilà donc il faut vraiment prendre
le temps de l'analyser et adapter les
situations voilà donc l'expérimentation
ce qui raté l'idéal c'est d'aller au
bout et retirer les enseignements donc
le gouvernement va un peu plus vite
c'est son choix c'est une méthode qu'on
retrouve souvent chez lui
sur un dossier que vous portez et qui
vous tient la question du handicap il y
a dans ce texte des mesures Audrey pour
les travailleurs en situation de
handicap oui avec un tout premier
chiffre au premier trimestre 2023 le
chômage de la population active en
situation de handicap à atteint 12%
c'est presque le double de la population
générale l'un des objectifs de ce texte
et de faciliter leur emploi dans les
entreprises ordinaires quand c'est
possible et puis le texte a aussi pour
ambition d'aligner les droits des
travailleurs des établissements ou
services d'aide par le travail les ESAT
sur les salariés ordinaires j'ai appris
hier lors de l'audition c'est le
ministre du travail qu'il a annoncé que
80% des travailleurs à temps plein dans
les ESAT n'avaient pas de mutuelle alors
pourtant hier vous avez sonné vous avez
tiré la salade d'alarme les mots dans
l'ordre c'est mieux justement sur cette
harmonisation pourtant ça part d'un bon
sentiment
je suis extrêmement favorable et de
nouveau c'est un débat de la méthode
parce qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui d'avoir
des ESAT qui accueillent des personnes
qui sont de handicap notamment celles
qui sont les plus éloignées de l'emploi
et lorsque vous commencez à réformer
donc quelque part en créant des charges
supplémentaires sur des structures qui
ont déjà du mal à équilibrer un tiers
sont déficit sans leur proposer la
moindre outil de transformation
d'accompagnement financier et bien on
peut craindre que ça soit la fin du
modèle donc plutôt favorable à cette
initiative mais de nouveau on peut pas
tout casser et se retrouver avec une
méthode qui entraîne peut-être plus de
conséquences négatives donc voilà donc
j'ai alerté en disant oui pour cette
réforme là mais il faut à tout prix
accompagner des zézettes dans leur
transformation et surtout leur donner
les moyens financiers d'exister c'est
des structures qui sont à la fois du
médico-social mais qui ont besoin de
faire de l'économie et donc il faut leur
donner les moyens pour pouvoir
fonctionner correctement
vous avez demandé hier aussi à mieux
identifier les emplois qui pourraient
être effectués par des personnes à la
situation de handicap dans les
entreprises classiques tout à fait
cercle c'est une des missions de Cap
Emploi qui pour moi passionnément
clairement rédigé donc on va travailler
là-dessus parce qu'on se rend compte que
finalement beaucoup d'entreprises
n'imagine même pas qu'ils ont des postes
finalement où la capacité d'accueillir
des personnes de situation de handicap
selon handicap il y a aussi le handicap
invisible il n'y a pas simplement que
des gens lourdement handicapés et donc
l'idée c'est que simplement au-delà de
même de répondre à une proposition d'une
entreprise c'est qu'on puisse prendre le
temps de visiter rencontrer et
d'analyser finalement si la l'entreprise
a une capacité réelle à travers ses
postes ces métiers de pouvoir accueillir
des travailleurs handicapés donc rentrer
dans l'entreprise faire ce lien entre le
médico-social la structures qui
s'occupent de l'emploi et l'entreprise
voilà et je pense que c'est une
véritable opportunité je suis dans une
région où toutes les entreprises
recherches du personnel et on a testé
clairement cette ce lien avec le monde
du handicap et lorsque les entreprises
se rendent compte que finalement ils
peuvent travailler ensemble c'est
on a toujours des retours extrêmement
favorables donc il faut aller plus loin
dans l'émission de Cap emploi
que l'objectif premier de sexe c'est
d'atteindre le plein emploi vous avez
additionné Olivier du sobretière est-ce
que ce texte va permettre de l'atteindre
le plan d'emploi je peux pas répondre à
cette question en tous les cas si tu
l'initiatique était nécessaire de
coordination je veux dire on a évoqué
les limites du texte voilà je crois
qu'ils ont doit réagir votre résumé
parfait on a des demandes d'emploi qui
restent nombreux on a des entreprises
qui ont des besoins de recrutement voilà
et on voit bien que plus on baisse le
taux le le taux de gérer le taux du
chômage plus on se retrouve avec des
publics qui sont parfois éloignés et
donc c'est pas simplement une réponse à
une offre il faut les accompagner et
Nexo social il y a même de l'insertion
voilà donc il faut adapter les outils
mais de nouveau je pense que cette
politique de l'emploi doit être avant
tout une politique régionalisée
territorisée donc attention au travers
de ce texte de loi merci Audrey là oui
on va parler de la répartition des
demandeurs d'asile dans les territoires
et dans les campagnes ce sera à suivre
dans le club on va parler politique et
des républicains Philippe Millet les
cadres de renaissance étaient réunis
hier Renaissance le parti présidentielle
pour définir leur ligne par rapport aux
République ils veulent éviter
l'immobilisme c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
est-ce que ça passe par une alliance
avec vous alors pour moi l'alliance
c'est de circonstances mais une alliance
fondamentale non j'ai depuis
l'élection avec ce petit on a réaffirmé
et notamment aussi au Sénat que nous
étions plutôt une démarche où on est
capable d'être avec le gouvernement
texte par texte mesure par mesure mais
on n'est pas du tout sur une alliance se
structurelle parce que nous avons des
grandes différences parce que nous
sommes surtout enfin pas en accord sur
les méthodes proposées parfois sur la
personnalité des acteurs donc voilà donc
je crois que là-dessus on change pas
notre ligne pour l'architecture
d'indépendance on entendait parce que
vous êtes réunis vous êtes et samedi les
états généraux de la droite et on
entendait par exemple Rachida Dati dire
mais on va pas faire qu'à tront comme ça
oui parce que un moment donné il faut
réellement que le gouvernement et
laisser de volonté de travailler avec
nous parce que je vois bien comment ça
se passe et généralement au moment du
texte de loi on discute on a des
rapprochements qu'on regarde ensuite
l'application de la loi la sortie des
circulaires on fera bien compte qu'il y
a une différence donc voilà je crois
qu'à un moment donné soit on est une
vraie capacité de travailler ensemble
sur des textes qui correspondent à nos
sensibilités politiques et on va
jusqu'au bout de la démarche
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à l'application des
lois soit alors bien on est d'un côté
allié sur un texte pendant ce temps-là
vous avez un ministre qui fait des
annonces comme le miser l'économie sur
les 10 milliards sans concertation voilà
donc je crois que les choses les choses
sont claires nous sommes toujours dans
une démarche où l'intérêt des Français
pour nous essentiels de la France donc
il faut savoir se mettre autour de la
table j'espère que sur le texte de
l'immigration ça sera le cas mais en
même temps
rouge oui c'est ça c'est un point sur
lequel il faut dialoguer c'est ça la
constatation là en ce moment on a
beaucoup évoqué le futur texte qui va
être traité au Sénat sur notamment la
loi de programmation militaire sur des
sujets sur lequel et bien on va je pense
trouver des accords même si on a encore
des discussions sur les engagements
financiers oui donc je crois qu'on est
capable de travailler ensemble sur des
textes qui portent l'intérêt de la
France et puis en même temps on allait
venir sur lequel on n'est pas du tout en
accord dans lequel et bien nous avons
nous marqueurs voilà et je crois que si
l'alliance est formelle bah ça veut dire
qu'on n'existe plus c'est-à-dire qu'on
est plus dans l'opposition donc on
n'existe plus comme si c'est plus en
politique ça la fin triste toujours et
vous pensez continuer pouvoir continuer
à exister de manière indépendante est-ce
que si vous ne passez pas une alliance
avec Emmanuel inconven vous n'allez pas
être coincé entre Emmanuel Macron et le
rassemblement national
de ce que vous avez vécu par le
potentiel en échange de quoi je pense
que si on fait une alliance et Macron
que ça en existe plus du tout tout de
suite donc pas de remaniement avec
dessinateur au gouvernement ah moi je
sais pas voilà mais on verra on verra ce
qui va se passer merci beaucoup merci
Philippe nier d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure dans
20 minutes dans le club des territoires
débat sur la proposition d'Emmanuel
Macron de répartir les migrants sur
l'ensemble du territoire de sénateur en
débattrons Jacqueline nostalgie pour les
républicains et François patriar patron
des sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle mais d'abord on va
accueillir un autre sénateur servait
Marseille qui nous rejoint